اما بيني جانس الوزير في حكومه الحرب
الاسرائيليه فقال ان اعاده المختطفين
احياء مهمه جدا وان عودتهم ليست اولويه
فحسب بل هي واجب اخلاقي على الدوله واكد
جانس ان ذلك لا يتناقض مع مهمه تدمير حماس
على حد
تعبيره سمعنا في الايام الاخيره تسريب
اشاعات واخبار بشان صفقات تبادل وهي تؤذي
العائلات والجهود الكبيره التي نبذلها
عاده المختطفين ليست مهمه من حيث الزمن
فقط وانما واجب اخلاقي على الدوله وهذا
امر عاجل ولا يتناقض مع واجب ازاله تهديد
حماس الذي لن نتخلى عنه كهدف ابدا اعاده
المختطفين احياء مهمه جدا وهي ما يميزنا
كمجتمع مزدهر ومحب للحياه هناك ما نقاتل
من اجله واجبنا ان نجيد اتخاذ القرارات
الصحيحه في المستقبل اذا طرح مقترح مناسب